when President Putin launched his
invasion on the 24th of February it was
the start of death and destruction in
Ukraine but the reverberations were felt
around the world including almost 8 000
kilometers away in the corridors of the
U.N in New York
I called to order the
9143 session of the security Council
what had happened was clear-cut a
permanent member of the U.N security
Council had breached one of the main
tenets of the organization's founding
Charter One country should never invade
another
Russia's veto power meant the security
Council was paralyzed instead on three
occasions Russia was left almost
isolated in votes in the U.N General
Assembly
some had feared the war would lead to
the virtual collapse of the U.N
but looking back the Secretary General
of the UN Antonio Gutierrez told me he
was pleased that the organization had
some limited successes on the ground the
U.N is a complex organization that has
different dimensions and different parts
obviously for the security Council this
war has been a very
dramatic factor of inefficiency
but this war has demonstrated the
enormous value of humanitarian action
led by un and U.N agencies this has
demonstrated that the UN is probably the
only platform that was able to seriously
talk with both sides to try to solve not
to war unfortunately but some specific
problems that have dramatic impacts at
Global level
the UN organized the evacuation not just
of the Ukrainian Fighters but also of
women and children from the other style
steel Works in mariopol in May then in
July working with Tokyo the UN arranged
a deal to allow grain ships to once
again cross the Black Sea partly
alleviating the global food crisis I
think that guitarish has really stepped
up in response to this war he's
previously had a reputation for caution
he's had a reputation for not
challenging the major Powers but in this
case he has stepped in personally to a
lot of diplomacy around humanitarian
issues in Ukraine and also the global
food crisis and I think he's gained
credibility on the world stage as a
result of his efforts the Secretary
General has made it clear that he
doesn't see any chance of meaningful
negotiations to end the war anytime soon
instead the UN is focusing on trying to
further alleviate the suffering they
want to extend and and expand the Black
Sea grain initiative and to work with
the international Committee of the Red
Cross to arrange a mass prisoner
exchange between Ukraine and Russia
despite the un's limited diplomatic
achievements over the past 10 months the
situation is still extremely delicate
the U.S and its NATO allies want the UN
to send an investigation team to examine
claims that Iranian drones have been
used by Russia but Al Jazeera
understands the Secretary General is
stalling because he fears Russia will
then pull out of the grain deal James
Bay's Al Jazeera at the United Nations